I've been a fan of yours for a while but
if someone has never seen anything that
you've done before what is the first
thing you want them watching and why
Queen and slim
yeah that's kind of good that's my
calling card it's my first movie that I
ever starred in and it's an incredible
film and I think if anyone's gonna start
trying to get to know me as a performer
that that's a pretty great place to
start I can only imagine how much fun it
is actually who was the most excited in
your life that you were going to do a
movie with Adam Sandler or Jennifer
Aniston hmm I think my husband
I think my husband was the most excited
well other than myself yeah of course
yeah and then my acting coach is really
excited too if what I can only imagine
what it's like actually sharing scenes
with them because I'm a big fan of both
of theirs and uh so what was it actually
like what surprised you about working
with them just how
cool they are
I mean like
cool but they actually like like cool
down to earth warm collaborative kind
I mean you know the the energy in the
atmosphere on the set I mean they they
you know a lot of the crew of like are
people that they've worked with for
years and you can feel that and there's
no no one is being an and
they're really nice and they're like I'm
like they want me to be here and and and
I'm their peer right now and that's wild
and crazy and and they're
um they're open to jokes that I have or
suggestions or whatever and my energy
and it just was like
it just didn't feel like I was working
with people that had massive egos or
like nothing and like Adam calm says
playing his music and Jen is like
literally one of the coolest people I've
ever met in my life and it was just like
you know you know you have expectation
and reality and like reality exceeded my
expectations and I just love when I have
that kind of experience in life that's
really nice I've been doing this job for
a while and I've been fortunate enough
to interview both of them a few times
and it is crazy how nice they are for
you you know like it's it's really
refreshing yeah I mean you know it's
it's to be in the business and I've been
working for as long as they've been
working and at the level of Fame that
they both have and to be so grounded and
like open you know not insulated and
closed off and angry is a is amazing you
know because it is not easy you've
worked on a number of things uh how
would you rate like the fun factor in
filming this one because and also the
shooting locations which is crazy this
is the most fun I've ever had on on a
movie like Bar None this is the most fun
I've ever had on a movie it was just
like all laughs and fun and beautiful
beautiful locations I I mean
it's insane and like Chic hotels and
just like it was so fun and glamorous
and like then you're laughing all day at
work and I mean it was a it was a dream
job
um what do you think fans of murder
mystery murder and murder mystery 2 uh
would be surprised to learn about the
actual making of the movie I don't know
if people are gonna be uh ready for the
amazing action sequences of one Jennifer
Aniston in this film okay yeah it's like
where is her secret agent film
um that's actually true uh the Eiffel
Tower stuff in this is uh is pretty
academic it's huge it's epic yeah
absolutely epic and even just like I
mean the fan scene yeah thank you it's
incredible I mean it's just it's really
it's action-packed uh yeah there's two
huge set pieces yeah maybe three
actually
um listen I'm a big fan of sex education
and I know you've joined for the next
season uh and I have to ask you what was
it like joining the show and what can
you tease if anything about your role I
can't use anything
but I can say that
I absolutely love shooting
and it was an honor to work with him uh
I can't wait
um but something that maybe you can say
a little bit more although who knows uh
you got to join the Star Wars Universe
yes and um that show I'm really looking
forward to because I may or may not know
some things about it which I will not
say but how much fun did you have
playing in that Universe oh my God that
was also really really fun and obviously
like the subject matter is different
it's different when like everything that
you're doing is light-hearted and like
that's not what I was doing for Star
Wars but I was working with my favorite
director that I've worked with so far
coconada and it was just you know under
the leadership of Leslie Headland it is
incredible to see I can't wait to see
how this show turns out Amandla is such
an incredible performer I unfortunately
didn't have any scenes with her but I
got to see a little bit of what they've
been doing and I'm just
I think it's going to be epic and it's
nothing that anyone has seen before
inside of that universe that's exactly
it I'm going to ask you did you get to
hold or use a lightsaber I didn't get
to use a lightsaber got it
but I did
not get to use a lightsaber I understand
completely because I am not a Jedi
I um I'm not trying to uh pressure you
too oh you can't yeah no I I think that
um I'll switch to something else or I
won't get you in any trouble you got to
shoot something recently with Vince
Vaughn
um and uh no one is asking about bad
monkeys you're the first person right
I'm a big fan of Vince um what was it
like working with him because he's also
very very funny yes he is hilarious and
I actually had the best time working
with fans and I was so mad at Bill
Lawrence because we only had like three
scenes together and I was like hello we
need I need more with Vince because
every time he worked together and Vince
was like we need to do more it was so
much fun working with him yeah can you I
gotta go real quick what's it about for
people that don't know okay so it's
actually based on a book Carl hyacin
novel
um about this former police officer
um who's living in the Florida Keys who
uh discovers uh as a severed arm in the
water and it's the mystery of all that
and I play
um a local Obi woman from the Bahamas
who is
somewhat involved in all that is going
on and that no no need to go I'm just
going to say I'm really happy for
everything that's happening with you
thank you for giving me your time